bring in jewel class fox sports college
football analyst and he's got Michigan
and Wisconsin
Joel thanks for joining us let me start
with Wisconsin give me a scenario where
if Wisconsin runs the table they don't
make the final four oh gosh I don't
think that will happen but I think that
the wild chance that there's just an
epic ACC championship game
and Miami loses late maybe a field goal
late maybe an overtime game and everyone
is so enthralled with Clemson in Miami
and and let's say that you know Penn
State for some reason gets into the big
ten championship game and that
championship game is less than grilling
and then all the sudden the four teams
that are sitting in the top four right
now we're just kind of remain in the top
four if Oklahoma and Alabama are on the
table I guess that would be your
scenario but I think it was again it
would have to be some sort of epic ACC
championship game where people think
even Miami with a law deserves to be in
the top four what are the chances
Michigan wins this game you know I give
them probably better chance and even
Vegas does I know it's like seven and a
half a stump along those lines the thing
that I get worried about for each team
in this game Dan is that each defense is
going to take away to run at least for
some portions of the game so then it
becomes which passing game is ready to
take over the game and I don't know if
either of these are and the only thing
that Michigan's got going for it even
though they've got a young quarterback
who's not proven he doesn't turn the
ball over he's very safe with the
football and the Hornibrook is not you
know he turns it over and he'll put it
up there last week the only points that
I was scored for the 14 on six sixes you
know so I think that is is the scenario
where Michigan can potentially not only
stay close but even come in here and
upset Wisconsin and Camp Randall give me
your top four and your rationale for
ranking those top four yeah you know in
this day and age right like you've got
to look at the whole resume at least in
my estimation so when I was drinking my
top floor this week I put Oklahoma at
number one and it's a pretty simple
rationale I think that if you beat great
teams that you are a great team and they
have three top 15 wins that's more than
rest of the top five combined all those
teams are still currently in the top 15
which i think is more important than
what one's and was able to do when they
beat three top 15 teams early in the
season that are you know some of them no
longer ranked like jigna tech by the way
they won all those games stand by 10
points or more they've got the number
one offense in the country the best
player in the country and two of them
along the road
so there's the number one team in the
country for me Alabama goes in number
two I've got Miami a three and then
Wisconsin at four the thing that that I
look at with crimson is they cannot
throw the ball Kelly Bryant's been given
kind of a pass-by display off committee
and in reality he's only thrown for 200
or more yards twice in the last seven
games that's not gonna cut it coming
down the stretch so I think they're
actually in trouble when they meet Miami
in that champagne okay you got us C in
UCLA normally this is an interesting
game competitive game might be the last
time Jim mortgage to face USC as the
head coach at UCLA but you also have Sam
darn old and Josh Rosen we cooled off a
little bit on these two but if I said
who will go higher in the draft with Sam
Donald and Josh Rosen who would you take
I would take Sam's Arnall and I think
most of the NFL guys that I thought too
would echo those sentiments his his
struggles have been overblown you and I
both know that when someone comes in
with all the hype that that Donald does
even answer documented his last season
with that side behind it's very
difficult to live up to that and so he
turned the ball over a few times early
in the seat and yes certainly those were
bad turnovers but if you look at his
whole body of work then it's actually
been pretty outstanding his rating
against ranked opponents this year is
153 that third in the country behind
only Baker Mayfield and Mackenzie Milton
from UCF meanwhile Rosen went healthy
he's certainly one of the best players
out there but I will tell you this don't
be shocked if Josh Rosen stays at UCLA I
don't know if it's the first time you've
heard this or not but I wouldn't be
shocked if both of these players are
back but in particular roses roses an
interesting one where you may have an
alliance being built you know in Jim
Mora very close and there may be an
alliance being built where you know
they're kind of making it a package deal
we're in space Josh will stay as well
and the gym though
then Joshua will go so that met UCLA
situation is very interesting I think
that he has seen the the writing on the
wall with some of the sentiment in the
NFL and he knows he's got to curb some
of those you know I guess rumors out
there about maybe his attitude and and
love of the game now I think he loves
the game I think he's a great player
I think Josh Rosen may be back at UCLA a
year from now that's the first I've
heard of that you know we talked about
Sam Donald is possibly going back as
well we're talking to Joel clad from Fox
Sports he's got Wisconsin Michigan
coming up this weekend but I talked to
Rick Neuheisel and Neuheisel knows
quarterbacking and he said if he had the
number one pick or he needed a
quarterback that one quarterback he's
taking his Baker Mayfield head you know
how did Mayfield go from and he's been
around we've seen him and normally when
you stay too long
you know we devalue you he's increased
yeah thank you here how did that happen
well he got better every year which is
you know that's one way I'm with you and
I don't know if I would take him as the
first quarterback but boy it would be
close and there's one thing that you're
seeing in the National Football League
right now which is young quarterback
that had successful as leaders and
winners in the college game that are
going in and having a lot of success in
the National Football League won is the
schematics aren't necessarily changing
but then you don't have to be under
sinner quite as much as you used to be I
mean every team in the National Football
League is in the shotgun close to
seventy percent of the time seventy five
to ten at a time so the transition is
not quite what it was let's say five six
seven years ago
Mayfield also has this innate ability to
make throws and that's one thing that
gets lost is everyone thinks it's a
spread system and that's where the
numbers are so gaudy but when you watch
him play he's got terrific arm talent he
drives to football down the field he
throws with great touch he can layer the
ball over the linebackers in front of
the safeties and his teammates love
playing for him and I got to tell you I
don't think that there is a more fun
player for watching college football
right now that number six for the
Oklahoma Sooners you know and what is
always struck me as strange and
counterintuitive is that the NFL wants
the quarterback to adjust to the NFL
style when the NFL borrows more from
college than the other way around that
are we seeing pro teams now shift a
little bit more back to college so the
transition like Carson Wentz or jarred
golf or deshaun Watson it's an easier
transition for these kids to be able to
play in a style that they're comfortable
with no question about it and and
there's some things that you're never
going to be able to copy namely I think
two things that will always maintain you
know some difference between the two
games is the space that wide pass marks
create in the college game but just not
afforded to you in the National Football
League so you don't have the space to
run the type of schematics that you do a
solid level and then to is the 53-man
roster that just doesn't allow you to
play with the tempo that the college
teams play with does the attrition
that's just two three so those two
things are always going to put some
barriers on copying exactly what a
college team does and taking it to the
National Football League but I will say
you're exactly right when you're looking
at the concepts that are being run when
you're looking at the number of snaps in
the shotgun when you're looking at the
way that they are teaching not only
teaching but then also calling the plays
on the football field it's a lot
different than it used to be used to be
so much Burbage and guys in the college
game that hadn't been in a huddle really
struggled with that well now in the NFL
they're adapting a lot of those single
word concepts that tell everyone what
they're doing and I think that's a big
difference and interestingly enough then
the team that really brought that to the
NFL it wasn't teams trying to find a
quarterback it was the patriot yeah the
Patriots are the ones that started doing
it and so everyone said oh well the
thing to do it we can do it too and oh
by the way we've got some quarterbacks
that are young that can execute what
they're doing yeah when Belichick goes
to visit Mike Leach that tells you about
Mike Leach and what they were doing at
Texas Tech a long long time ago and then
belcheck adopted that system or at least
a hybrid of that in New England I'll
leave you with this the sneaky game this
weekend aside from the one you have of
course with Fox on with Wisconsin
Michigan is professional professional
piece I would say Texas Tech TCU that
the interesting one for me because TCU
controls their own destiny but Dan Texas
Tech is top ten in the country thrown
the ball with Nick Shem an active 5th
year senior at quarterback
Kliff Kingsbury got them playing much
better than they have the last few years
particularly fence and TCU just lost a
really emotional game to Oklahoma week
ago and their best player on offense
Darius Anderson that is a sneaky game
that could allow Oklahoma State to get
back into that big flow of championship
game which is the last thing that the
Oklahoma Sooners want that's the one
matchup they desperately want to avoid a
Dallas so that game Texas Tech can see
see you at the big great stuff Joel tell
Gus we said hello and thanks for
allowing us to catch up with you you got
it man thank you so much for having me
it's been fun that's a Joel Klein Fox
Sports
it's a Michigan and Wisconsin coming up
this weekend on funk for more Dan
Patrick show to the audience channel 239
on DirecTV or download the Dan Patrick
show app
[Music]